is the series over John I have a
different feeling than last year I know
Golden State trounced Cleveland in the
first two games but there's one
difference this year and that's number
35 so yes I say it's over over is in
sweet now now there's going to be a
penalty John if somehow in Cleveland
comes back and wins this there's going
to be a like a really stiff penalty on
you I'm not concerned about that I do
believe that they can win Game three
you have the best player in the world so
you have a chance but he does need some
help you know Shumpert gr Smith Deron
Williams go 1 for 13 I believe Steph
Curry's out rebound in Tristan Thompson
to this point
ouch that's that's typically not good so
he needs a little bit of help and I
thought he was a little bit fatigued
last night I mean he started the game
driving to the rim and his first eight
field goals were all in the restricted
area and then he just kind of starts
settling for jump shots I think when he
gets fatigued and you know is a big
difference is instead of playing free
safety and guarding Harrison Barnes and
daring him to shoot he's guarding a guy
that's pretty good score well it's all
about matchups as you know when you get
to the finals and you know unlike last
year you know you could match up with
everybody last year and even have some
advantages with with Durant
he's just the unicorn in there that you
just they're you know who guards him if
LeBron doesn't garden yeah they really
don't have many options they put
Shumpert on them and I thought the
Warriors missed Kevin a lot in the low
post area that he had him posted up well
yeah there's really nobody I mean you
could try Richard Jefferson or Shumpert
um but the guy 7 feet tall he's going to
shoot over whoever it is he could post
he's I mean how about the defense 5
blocks
um it's just the Warriors are just
they're so skilled at every position and
it's just to make it 132 points and they
turn it over 20 times I know Cleveland
turned over 20 times and gave ones 491
so 40 more points with the same amount
of turnovers they're that good
offensively what do you think LeBron is
thinking right now you know uh uh we
need more they have four stars we have
to let them is I I don't know whether
would I was just shocked the way they
came out and game want to defend it or
as does what John McKay would say he'd
be in favor of some defense of execution
because they didn't do any of it um
what's the plan you knows one-on-one
basketball that's just that's just the
way they play and the school of state
Wars or better were last year and
they're taking Cleveland out everything
they want to do explain why there's such
a good defensive team I think people
focus on the offense and I say the
defense really sets up a lot of what
they do offensively but you having
played and now you're you know analyzing
this for the mothership what is it why
is that defense so good the length and
athleticism of every single guy that's
on the floor basically I mean I guess
you could say Steph doesn't have the
length but he's a great athlete a steals
guy I'm not the greatest defender in the
world but you know smarts together this
all tied into what what they need to do
knowing a guy's going to rotate behind
you if you make a mistake on you know
sticking to the game plan they make very
few mistakes and I thought the tone of
the series we go back to Game one klay
Thompson got switched out to Kevin Love
and he made a defensive play that was it
by the way his defense is off the charts
Kyrie Irving had no chance last night
but he made a play on Kevin Love the
first game first play of the game were
played against Cleveland and I just
thought it set the tone and people just
want to talk about the offense as they
should because it's fun to watch they
score points and they shoot the ball and
but their defenses as good as it's not
the best by the way we're talking to
John Barry the mothership working for
ESPN Radio pregame halftime and postgame
if I'm if I'm LeBron right now I wonder
if if I would be thinking about next
year like okay I'm down to oh I'm going
back home but is there a thought process
says Durant's going to be there for a
little while I mean this nucleus is
going to be there for a while and if I
want greatness and I want to be
mentioned with Jordan I'm not going to
win titles the way we're playing or what
we have here do you see that element of
hey I got to go out and get some help in
the offseason yeah I would hope that
he's not thinking about that right now
and I certainly doubt that he is they
were down to Oh again just like I said
from last year so there's got to be some
sort of belief that they go home and do
this no one gave a chance down 3-1 and
quite frankly we all know they would
have lost it draymond Green was playing
Game five but nonetheless I mean you
have to go eat go home believe you're
gonna play better at home hopefully you
know Shumpert and jr. and these guys can
you know make some shots alleviate a
little depression off LeBron but
absolutely regardless of what happens
this bench has to get a lot younger they
need they need another playmaker on this
team it's too much to ask of LeBron on a
nightly basis I think he's worn down I
really do I've seen in a couple games I
saw it in Game three against Boston uh
there's nights that he just physically I
think he does bleed red I think people
don't want to believe that but he's
human
is this a great one of the great teams
of all time we're seeing with Golden
State not a nominal guy now it's hard
for me to say that yeah but you've been
around him you saw the Jordan Bulls
you know you were there you were there I
don't know how you quantify what's
greatest of all time you know they do
point to French all these analytics here
this team throwing as many games as the
previous year so if they're breezing
through Cleveland is that going to
factor in on just how great this team
hell they're recognized well it's not an
indictment of the Eastern Conference
that Cleveland can roll through losing
one game and if they get rolled and four
by this team I give them credit it's
just a different game we you know just
yeah you have to say that because this
is the way the game is played it's a
completely different game than we saw in
the 70s age and all that so yeah they
are they are that great it what's going
on now but like when I think
to the Lakers and the Celtics in the 80s
like a man for man can you say that
these guys are better than those guys
no I don't I don't he can but it's a
different game and I don't think that
those guys these are things that these
guys are capable doing now it's the
athleticism the shooting the skill the
skill of every single guy that's out
there on the floor at all the times
those teams didn't have it certainly
most of the guys did but seems like
everybody for the worse has en Clark was
going on I mean all these guys where
they just stayed there so tied together
and you know what Steve Kerr deserves so
much of the credit it's great to see him
back to you by the way and one of the
best guys you meet the NBA I'm so happy
that he's able to sit on the bench when
Kevin Durant's name comes up as great
players it usually goes to well he's one
of the great scorers in the game is
Kevin Durant a great player
absolutely not a lot of credit for his
defense five blocks last night I thought
all year he played great defense he's
absolutely a great player I think a lot
of bad habits from his first few years
the way they played in Oklahoma City was
very isolated isolation basketball was
kind of your turn my turn Russell would
go one-on-one and Katy would go
one-on-one and stand around and he's
learned how to play basketball the
proper way and now he's doing that he's
eating a greater player Jeff Van Gundy
said that to curry and Durant the best
duel of all time oh stop Jeff sobbing it
really so rihanna is the greatest of all
time - I mean come on Gia okay so where
do you start there with the Korean
Durant if they're not the greatest duo
of all time who you got well I mean
don't you have to go Pippen and Jordan I
don't know do you with the titles you
could go magic Kareem you could go
Russell and anybody else let's see one
zillion times now I wouldn't go there
but
yeah I mean I think about you know
stopping them alone but no titles so
that's not good enough nowadays right
yeah um Dre I don't know a title yet
correct so having even to put them in a
conversation with magic and curry I
don't know I don't know it's Van Gundy
maybe you're cold I know he's the best
yeah but I don't know that I can go
there like you said without a title for
Kb let's stop and even if it's one we I
don't think we can go there how's morale
mechanic magical entering house from
around the airport fantastic yeah
beautiful Skyrim air express little
oatmeal and I'm ready to head out in
Cleveland
alright shave travels so I was great to
talk to you thanks dude all right look
up John Barry mothership work in ESPN
Radio Monty you just see thanks Dave
well that might have been a running joke
that we had Dave it's early to Jonathan
up well I think I probably called him by
the wrong name on purpose when we work
together you called him Rick and Brant
or Jimmy or something I remember maybe
that's what happened
thanks Dave yeah the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you